hey oh Jesus Christ
hi there I'm Sam heuen and these are my
favorite snacks cue
snacks being thrown at me from afar
[Music]
this is my first snack actually it's a
cinema snack of course it's got to be
popcorn at the cinema right
I get upset when I come to America
because you guys only have like really
bad popcorns in the UK we have
sweet and salty these are really salty
so what you do is you get half and half
sweet and salty buy a box of M M's only
the green ones will do
and then you just mix them up right and
it is absolutely delicious you can share
them while you're in the cinema if you
want and you get these little bits of
chocolate goodness which is sweet or
salty popcorn we have the single picker
mix in the UK where you get to pick all
these different kinds of candies put
them in a bag and you get this real mix
so you never know what's going to come
next this is about as close as I can get
to in America I pick a mix it goes
everywhere that's my fresh snack
aha yes
this one is a classic these are the
tunics Tea cake why are they called tea
cakes I have no idea maybe they should
be served with tea just don't throw any
tea at me right now
um yes they're from Scotland there are
different ways of eating one you might
want to just bite into it you might want
to pick at the chocolate first you can
take the top layer off like this and on
inside is this marshmallow layer or you
can crush it
tastes like heaven like you're on a
really fluffy bed soft marshmallow sweet
milk chocolate everything from Scotland
is basically sweet we like sweet stuff
but these are really honestly a classic
get your hands on some tunics tea kicks
delicious
is this a snack I hear you ask
is it's a snack I mean if you're trying
to be healthy and actually I find this
is a really great snack if you like
working out I love adding protein powder
to my Greek yogurt
um adds more protein you get flavor if
you get chocolate protein or strawberry
that changes your yogurt into like this
like chocolate smoothie kind of texture
have you noticed though when putting
protein powder into anything it just
goes absolutely everywhere like no
matter if you're just trying to get it
in when you're putting your protein
Shaker it's everywhere
yeah but delicious don't forget to stir
it though first I do like to train one
of my jobs that I work on I wear a kilt
and a spot in so you need a snack that
can fit inside your spa and it's the wee
pouch you wear on your kilt I don't
think this would last very long in your
sport
[Music]
this is disgusting
keep going
maybe I should pour a little bit back
what do you think
oh God
yeah
there you go whiskey and chocolate
delicious get your chocolate you pour
whiskey over it and eat it like that no
that's not true look I love a little uh
treat in the evening I don't have a
particularly Sweet Tooth but a nice
little bit of dark chocolate always goes
down really well with some really
delicious award-winning whiskey it's a
snack that I happen to make myself and
it's delicious I have only just started
drinking and already I feel great
cheers whiskey is synonymous with
Scotland we have some incredible whiskey
producers and it was a passion of mine I
have an emotional response when I drink
it I think when I smell it it takes me
back to the highlands of Scotland it
takes me home we call it the spirit of
home I like all kinds of whiskey so much
so that I think I'm gonna smell of
whiskey after this because I'm literally
bathing it out
[Music]
ah look at that beautifully done dare I
open it
[Music]
oh Jesus Christ
there you go what is that I hear you ask
it's bars I'm broom it is a Scottish
drink it's creeping towards me
um Coca-Cola obviously is number one
everyone loves cook all around the world
apart from Scotland the number one soda
drink in Scotland is this delicious
organic natural drink no it's not
organic or natural in fact no one knows
what's in it
um it's this Ginger color in fact in
Scotland we call it Ginger you want a
can of Ginger what does it taste like
are phenomenal no one knows what the
flavor is it's this kind of rich
sugeriness and actually once when they
try to change the recipe in Scotland and
reduce the sugar
there was a national outcry because we
like our sugar in Scotland it's also a
hangover cure in Scotland and of course
in Scotland they like to mix it with
alcohol as well it's great
and look at the color
[Music]
brilliant
the last one here we go surprise me oh
hey what a catch
yes oh they're cute little shortbread
Scotty dogs shortbreads
um what is shortbread well again another
snack
from Scotland that's full of sugar and
made with oats probably butter
bit of salt and that's it and you get
these cute little Highland dogs
um they should make like a Loch Ness
monster shortbread that'd be pretty cool
and you bite the head off of it of
course
that would go really well with that
whiskey what's his name Hamish
my man was it wrong to dunk it yeah
that's wrong
foreign
[Music]
well thank you for watching me work my
way through all my favorite Scottish
snacks obviously the sassenack whiskey
and gin are two of my favorites
Shameless plug but they are delicious
and from Scotland I really enjoyed that
hope you enjoyed it too
[Music]
hello